اليوم سنقوم بعمل غيبوبة
سأتركها لا تزال تبدو جميلة على
الرغم من أن جميع هذه المنتجات في الواقع
بأسعار معقولة جدًا والكثير منها
يمكنك حتى الحصول عليه في متجر الدولار
الذي حصلت عليه بالفعل مثل
شحم المهرج الأبيض  الطلاء لذلك أحب استخدام
فرشاة ناعمة وتطبيق كل
ما تريده بخفة لجعل وجهك يبدو
وكأنه ميت ، كما تعلم أنه لا توجد
حياة فيه ، ولهذا السبب نجعلها
أكثر شحوبًا ونزيل الحياة  من
بشرتها ، كما ترون ،
بدأت تبدو وكأنها ميتة أكثر ، لذا
سأستمر في عمل لوحة ظلال العيون
لدمجها في الكثير من
الأشياء وأيضًا سنحصل على بعض
التجاعيد الداكنة هناك  في أي مكان
لديك مثل شق حيث
يذهب وجهك ، من الجيد دائمًا إبراز
ذلك ، وإذا كنت تريد أن تفعل مثل
مظهر مخيف ، فافعل ذلك بألوان داكنة حقًا
مثل الأسود ، كيف يمكنك صنع
دمك يمكنك مزج طعام الجيلاتين الأحمر
تضع صلصة الصويا الصبغية تلميحًا أصفر لطيفًا في
تلك القهوة التي يمكنك إضافتها  قم بإنهائه في
الشعر ، يمكنه أن يمشط
الشعر بإصبعي ، يمكنني فقط الاستمرار فيه
وسأجعله يبدو وكأنه كان
يأكل شخصًا تبدو وكأنها
زومبي رائع جاهزة لأكل الناس فقط